I've never used a dating app yeah bro
your [ __ ] Tick Tock is 22 million
followers but even crazier of a flex
honestly yeah I don't know just go
outside like I don't know why people
like these dating apps I think in person
is just so much better like yeah just go
out there like they will come just say
hey and walk outside like women are
throwing their bras at them slapping
them in the face of their panties isn't
that your experience as well like I
don't understand that's weird man that's
crazy I swear it's not Bryce like that
what's the most obscure place you've met
a woman
um that you've ended up having sex with
oh we don't have the caveat that God
damn it I mean it's usually like always
at functions
like [ __ ] you know parties and [ __ ] a
function yeah the house party he doesn't
get not even a house party like you
don't either shut up I know what a
function is okay dude that's an old ass
word it's like a corporate conference
yeah is that what you're talking about
yeah when he said function I thought
like Catalina wine mixer yeah that's
where I went with it yeah damn that's
not what he meant he meant like a house
party it ain't a function okay so you
just meet girls at these parties or if I
see them on Instagram I like slide in
the DMS what's your go-to how do you
break the ice hey
and then what then they say hey and if
they usually do two three wise I'm like
I'm in
you in La question mark
yes I am let's hang damn I mean it's
like this full is speed running DMS so
this will be tool assisted I'm just
gonna use the least amount of phrases to
get the digits on the clock High yeah
and she gave them
time two seconds
that's a PB for me guys oh my God
there's so many dudes in their cars
right now listening to this that are
like I [ __ ] hate right now yeah [ __ ]
you dude
it feels good when someone else is
getting this [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you man it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] that that's happening
you know there's dudes out there just
grinding Tinder yeah and hinge yeah all
day every day oh it's worse finally a
match it's World okay what do I say what
do I say and then he goes on I've never
used a dating app before dating him yeah
I'm walking outside
yeah yeah oh you just mean like DMS
right dating you're having messages uh
no damn I was on that when I was like 17
18. I don't even know if that's legal
bro what the [ __ ] I mean I was 18.
so wait oh that's like last week
it is it's on firing up yeah no and then
I stopped using it when they like tried
to make me pay I was like [ __ ] that yeah
yeah why no one makes Bryce Hall hey
it's like why would I pay to be on a
dating app I could just go outside and
just eat girls you know I'm saying hey
on the app I'm saying hey on Instagram
it's just a different app I'm saying hey
what the [ __ ] I just need an app to say
hey
there should be an app called hey yeah
and I just say you say hey she says Hey
with three wise and then it's all that's
it yeah I don't know why people make
dating so complicated is that was that
not your experiences when you were when
you were younger and single no when I
was single I tried to get on Raya and
they weight listed me and it just never
happened oh
this is your [ __ ] no you know it's
funny I know right I remember him being
mad about that
yeah I remember someone brought a
brighter like and he's just so pissed
he's like I'm [ __ ] I'm on the wait
list I think I was talking to Jimmy and
he was like yeah you should get on Ryan
I'm like I'm trying man they're like
yeah you know someone there
about your application like five eight
doesn't matter yeah how famous you are
low probabilities here isn't that what
Raya is it's for like famous people I
mean when I was on there I saw like a
few Instagram models yeah but then
everyone else is like I don't know no I
was on it for years like when it first
when it first came out it used to have
like a like an actual Council of people
that like chose to let you into the app
and [ __ ] what way back when it first
launched yeah so they would just like
pick like users that I guess the founder
knew or something I know because like my
ex-girlfriend before we started dating
at the time was one of those people
because I was waitlisted as well and she
wanted to make a big show of like how
like oh we're not that serious like I'll
get you on Raya and then we started
dating and then it was she was not happy
that she got you on there yeah and then
she was like why did I do that yeah she
was not happy about that but you know I
had it since he was like 12.
it's been around that long no it hasn't
been that long I think it's like five
six years maybe but now it's like they
open it up to everyone because they're
trying to make money now you can get on
tonight yeah exactly you want now it's
too late yeah I'm getting married yeah
it's fine yeah yeah just yeah just just
everyone literally everyone to this app
yeah just do friends only mode yeah
that's the funniest thing they do have
that which is like
really like yeah I'd be very weary of
someone who's on Riot being like I just
want to make friends yeah that's that's
cool you're like friends only until
Bryce says hey
and then he's no longer friends though
he's just you're just a dude like
yo Bryce Hall just [ __ ] I'm just
messing me hey how many why should I put
yeah I don't know man you don't want to
come off thirsty like I definitely want
to chill I don't want to go for a beer
or something so too what maybe what
about what's good that's kind of uh yeah
yeah do you guys see the [ __ ] with uh
Adam Levine and that Instagram model
dude yeah Sumner yeah yeah she like
posted some Tick Tock it was like I've
been having an affair Summoner Sumner
her name is Sumner this is the craziest
part so she came on Tick Tock was like
I've been having an affair with Adam
Levine he's married he has two kids the
reason why she made the video is because
he reached out like after their Affair
had ended or something like that like a
couple months later he dm'd her again
and was like hey I'm having a third
child and I want to name it Sumner
that's the wackest name to try to take
your child what the [ __ ] that makes it
so much worse if she had like a cool
name no and the worst part he said it
was a boy yeah yeah I have a new baby
boy coming can I name it Sumner yeah I
mean I think the worst part is that he's
naming it is
mistress now yeah but also it's a whack
name too like if it was like a cool name
I don't know like then it's like what
what name would you pick that's a good
question Chad is a cool name for you
Nick you know what I mean yeah something
yeah something yeah something cool like
Hassan you know so you can get uh stop
at TSA every time yeah like super chill
it's like a perk it comes along with it
you know stopping power yeah that is
that is wild what name would you pick
over here bagging on Sumner yeah I mean
I don't know Sumner is a hard name to
say yeah is it summer is it summer like
it's why is it both I've never heard
there there's something there's
something there for sure
yeah you know it's a horrible name Some
D's
that's what I would name the child yeah
yeah go ahead somebody's nuts this
weekend I was in [ __ ] Des Moines
you're kind of roasting this girl and I
say what's your name and she goes abriel
I say
I say Avril she's like yeah like Gabriel
without the G I'm like you were a
thousand percent a mistake like I'm like
that's so [ __ ] you were born and your
dad just looked at you and was like uh
what about Avril you know I mean like no
effort yeah they wanted they wanted a
boy with with that name Gabriel and they
were like yeah just knocked the g off
[ __ ] it that's what that's what they do
like the naming convictions of the South
is so awesome because like you
immediately know that the father wanted
a boy if the girl's name is Peyton yeah
you know what I mean it's like oh I know
what's going on uh Blake I mean I guess
Blake is like unisex now or the or the
inverse dude's name Ashley yeah or
Lindsay yeah you know yeah it's Bryce
Bryce is a unisex name right this is
Bryce is now what you understand his
name but I thought it was a [ __ ] dude
name of the the entire time but there's
like how do you feel about that unisex
AF
is like I'll [ __ ] a girl named Bryce
damn dude say my own name during sex
what could be better we have a Bryson
yeah
how do you guys just go off of each
other well you don't go off of each
other okay let's [ __ ] stop being sus
dude caught in 4k ew you dude got him
[ __ ] weird oh Bryce [ __ ] is this
horrible Bryce that like you used to
watch this on your phone and you're like
now I'm here and they're just doing this
to me I feel like Maddie smokes